i just want to say they should have let
me audition for boba fett did you not
see that little kid in attack of the
clones
he clearly would have grown up to look
like me
just saying
[Music]
apparently boba fett is officially
returning for the mandalorian season 2.
this is big news for star wars fans
remember when mandalorian was announced
people were already speculating is this
going to be
boba fett in there there was the boba
fett spin-off movie in the works for the
longest time looks like it's finally
happening
we're gonna react to the video from the
channel called who's
nick it's a small youtube channel but
it's great movie news breakdown you guys
should subscribe to this channel show
them some support
because seriously uh it's wonderful
wonderful movie news videos let's react
to this and talk about the news people
hey what's going on everyone
welcome back to the channel and today we
have some exciting news
for the mandalorian season two to talk
about
now my apologies for not having uploaded
in the past couple weeks
but i'm hoping to get back into the
swing of things and probably
try and do more like daily or weekly
news
type things because over the past week
or so there actually has been some
pretty
good news dropping here and there about
upcoming movies that had been put on
pawns
so as for today's news we're going to be
talking about the appearance of boba
fett
in the mandalorian season 2. so every
week the hollywood was pretty cool to
make sure hollywood
drops a weekly newsletter and in it they
usually have some sort of scoop that
they drop and this time they actually
revealed that tamora morrison who
portrayed jango fett in the prequel
films
is going to be reprising boba fett
and mandalorian scenes suggest that in
episode
5 of the first season entitled the
gunslinger
when mando went to tatooine the
mysterious figure that was teased at the
end of that episode that was walking up
towards fennec shan's body
was in fact boba fett
looked somewhat like mandalorian armor
on the character that walked up towards
fenech shan's body
so that is really cool to get
confirmation that yes
fett will be appearing in some capacity
in season
two which could also lead to a bigger
story and even potentially especially
some of the trade outlets have been
teasing and one point before the
mandalorian actually got off the ground
like one's going to be a boba fett
standalone movie
josh crank as the first director and
then later james
great reports coming out of that after
kathleen kennedy and some of the other
people lucasfilm had talked
about thanksgiving the kid would agree
that pretty cool news for a couple of
reasons and i guess the big one is that
this confirms that yes
boba fett did survive in the new
continuity because that was somewhat of
a topic of debate among
fans because in the aftermath novel
trilogy that got released which is
official canon there was some slight
references to the fact that boba fett
might have survived his encounter with
the sarlacc pit as he had in
the legends continuity but it was never
confirmed so
i guess this does confirm that yes boba
survived and he will be
appearing in season 2 presumably as an
aged bounty hunter
the other reason this is really cool is
because
it's actually reprising the world if you
guys remember the original
actor that portrayed boba fett was
jeremy bullock but in the
special editions and the re-releases
they did for the old trilogy
tomoya moira morrison actually dubbed
over the audio for boba fett
today trying to keep it in continuity
rather than just cast a new actor
entirely
so what do you guys think about this are
you excited because
you think that needs to come back and
think that his presence is
warranted in this show i'm really
curious to see if
mando is aware of who fett is or knows
of his exploits or
vice versa and how the two of them are
going to interact if they're going to be
friendly or involved
you'll just have to wait and see and
this also could tie into the larger
narrative that was tied to baby yoda
and the fact that scientist that was
trying to get him in the first season
was
from the camino cloning labs which is
where django
so if you like this video and you want
to see some more content like it hit
that subscribe button
and the bell icon next to it so you can
be immediately notified whenever i drop
new content it really helps me out if
you want to hit me up on social media to
talk about mandalorian season 2 or any
other upcoming
movies and tv shows you can find me in
the links down in the description box
and with all that being said i'll catch
you guys in the next one i mean just
learning that from the tie-in alone
with the sequence with someone walking
up to uh i mean now one's character
at the end of that scene i think the way
the the season was structured
was meant to have you believe that it
was gideon
but i feel like the way with the
mysterious
way they shot it you really just throw
in any characters not even boba fett in
season two be like is that character
yeah that's right but i can believe it
if they if they were setting it up to be
boba fett and maybe i'll bring back
mcnal wen's character in some way
i thought having her in the show it was
just a little bit underserved and that
was one of the episodes that wasn't as
well received as the other ones i mean i
know we liked it
but i know that a lot of the fan base
wasn't generally a huge fan of that
particular episode either way the
the news of boba fett officially
returning following
uh some more of the lore and the canon
that's not in the shows and the movies
but is still
considered canon i think it's a great
idea and of course it
i mean it just makes sense that if
you're gonna bring boba fett back
i'd actually be more excited about
mandalorian season two
as opposed to having his own movie his
boba fett's always been an interesting
costume yeah it's been an interesting
discussion because
if you just look at like the movies
that's all you go off of the original
trilogy
of that alone like it's kind of just
this glorified cameo character in a lot
of ways
became a lot more important with his
father jango fett in attack of the
clones and of course of how
that feeds into the clone army the clone
wars
it seems like with what season two of
the mandalorian is doing is they're
gonna be going more out of their way
to tie it in to the bigger
narrative of star wars i'm not sure i
feel about that yet i'm just gonna wait
for
the show itself to come back but with
the way it ended with gideon pulling out
the dark saber
so kitano is gonna be in season two
boba fett is gonna be in season two
reserving some of these elements more
for season two as opposed to third one
season one
is the better call overall i wonder how
much of this is disney exact putting
input of hey clone wars is still really
hot and still doing great let's throw it
in there you know
and this is also the hottest property we
have that's not that that's going to
continue
exactly and dave filoni being involved
with the mandalorian
i think you know and with his work on
clone wars this is something i'm much
i'm more excited about this than i am of
the idea of the prospect of them doing a
solo movie at boba fett yeah i think so
too because
we've had the mandalorian show to build
up the culture and all the aspects that
weren't in the
at least the original trilogy and i feel
like you could do more with his
character
you could get to know him but you can
even start out the episode where he
shows up literally with him escaping the
sarlacc
or something like that giving some
retribution for that wacky scream that
he left us
on not quite wilhelm but
it's there yeah but yeah and i think
that for as much as the first season was
kind of isolated doing its own thing
very
uh aside from baby yoda sort of keeping
tangentially related to the universe my
trepidation
and also hope with this my trepidation
is that
i'm afraid that season two they'll kind
of do what resident evil the
second movie did where first one didn't
have much stuff in it and then the
second one was like here's a bunch of
recognizable fan service and so i hope
they don't turn that up too hard i feel
like they could create a really nice
gradual
growth where in the first season it's
very isolated the second season we
start to open up the universe get a
couple more characters i think ahsoka
tano is great because we haven't seen
her live in any huge capacity
you know you have obviously boba fett's
like iconic
yeah um and i feel like that's kind of
enough and boba fett especially makes
all the sense because
he is part of the a culture and b you
never know he could be some kind of
legend to
our hero character himself i feel like
there's something you can do there i am
worried just because it does also seem
like an easy thing to go this is
successful throw them in you know
we'll sell boba fett toys again at the
same time yeah it seems natural
it's the mandalorian show and i'm happy
tomorrow morrison's returning i didn't
know about
him dubbing over for when they
re-released the trilogy those lucas cuts
that he did i didn't know about
that i thought he was cool as jango fett
in
attack of the clones we've seen the guy
in aquaman he still
looks pretty young considering that's
been so many decades since attack of the
clone it makes sense to cast
him in the role it's cool that he gets
to come back here uh i think i think
that's great he's a wonderful actor and
i'm sure he'll probably get something
a little bit more nuanced to actually do
considering who the character was of
jango fett and attack of the clones i'd
imagine that boba fett
wouldn't be as strict or opposed
to keeping his mask on
you know anyway guys you're excited for
this news leave your thoughts down below
boba fett finally coming back getting
what we wanted for so many years
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell we will be covering
the mandalorian season 2 on this channel
last but not least
jn valente to me you are kind of like
boba fett to our patreon page you show
up you make a
huge impression off of being rather
mysterious
and subtle and then all of a sudden i
don't know where you are but i feel like
your presence has been in our patreon
universe for so long
can't just disappear jn just can't
disappear and i'm hoping
that by putting this shout out there
it's going to incentivize you to finally
start sending me back your stream of
consciousness monologues
just like how i missed i miss you buddy
get back to me as soon as you can please
add on your joke hey
jn um so you know you're like a
mandalorian because
you never take your mask of secrecy off
and communicate directly with us thus
maintaining your
mystique so uh whenever your action
figure drops
get ready for for that and josh trank
will direct your movie
wouldn't it be fun if they got josh
trank to do the episode